let's go
next as we take phone calls
let's go to let's go back to rhode
island let's go to jen from providence
rhode island
hi david can you hear me yes i can jen
all right um is it some speaker weird um
all right so i have a question um i know
that you're interested in social and
history and everything sure have you
looked into what happened after the 1918
pandemic how there was a similar kind of
labor shortage and how workers used it
to demand higher wages and there was
kind of a social movement going on and
then the teamsters rose up that's very
important
yeah do you think we're kind of
repeating history with that and we might
be able to use this to our advantage to
get better wages yes in fact i did a
story on the wednesday show
about the spread of strikes and worker
protests across the country
and made the point that the pandemic may
have generated
the you know ideal maybe is a little too
much but favorable conditions for
workers to use newfound leverage
uh to demand better working conditions
and better wages now as far as 1918 and
the flu
i did not know i've studied the 1918
pandemic a bit and we've done one or two
interviews about it
i didn't know about the
impact there on strikes and worker
rights
beyond just it was the tail end of the
progressive era during which we saw
activism for wages and better working
conditions but as as
ushered in by the pandemic i wasn't
familiar with that and i will look into
it that sounds interesting
yeah and it was uh kind of the same
thing what's going on now there was a
huge wage gap and uh those workers that
for the first time were able to afford
things like automobiles and appliances
that were just coming into existence the
middle class rose to be until the you
know 1929 when the stock market crashed
so i kind of wonder you know we're at
the same wage gap that maybe we could
kind of make up some of the space yeah
like what they did 100 years ago that i
mean it's possible and we're going to
keep following these strike movements
and see see what they develop and you
know i would
from a from a self-centered standpoint i
would love that and a lot of times
people say david i don't understand like
why are you saying it would be good for
you
for workers to earn higher wages like
what how does that affect you and as
i've explained so many times before
the way i earn money is by people
getting memberships on my website and
buying the products and services sold by
my advertisers that's how that's how i
make money if an advertiser does well
they buy more ads
and so
if more people
have disposable income they're not
living paycheck to paycheck
that's dramatically growing the pool of
people that can afford to get a
membership or buy something from an
advertiser so i am thrilled about these
protests because i think that they're
the right thing and that workers deserve
rights and also from a selfish
standpoint as an entrepreneur it's great
for me as well and and so i don't get
the uh um wholehearted opposition that
we see from so many places
yeah i'm in a similar boat as that i'm a
waitress and people are going to tip
more if they have a little bit of extra
money in their pocket absolutely it's
demand side stimulus and whether you
know that that's what it is or you don't
working people understand that when
people have more money it's also better
for me
yeah and just better for the economy
overall and better for you know
depression things like that people are
just happier absolutely yeah all right
well i thank you you are my favorite
youtuber and hey it's my birthday
tomorrow so this is a good early
birthday present all right happy early
birthday jen from providence great to
hear from you
really really strong phone calls today
it's actually shocking me